Senator Tim Scott has just announced
some happy news he is getting married he
just proposed to his girlfriend Mindy He
Said She Said Yes Mindy thank you for
making me the luckiest man in the world
he who finds a wife finds what is good
and receives favor from the Lord that's
from Proverbs
18:22 is great for him he's 58 she's 47
though a lady never tells so obviously
this is a later in life marriage but a
wonderful I think it's terrific and I
wish the many many years of happiness
and I've had the pleasure of meeting
Senator Scott on a couple occasions and
he's a really terrific guy I think
that's all great but there is a little
voice inside me a little voice of that
political cynic crying out inside me
that makes me wonder hold on a second
here is Senator Scott in the running to
be Trump's VP